ja ein thema abseits von corona aber es
hat zu tun mit der bundesregierung mit
der neuen bundesregierung und mit dem
ein oder anderen was sich in den ersten
noch nicht einmal 100 tagen doch an
merkwürdigen dingen da zugetragen hat
und da komme ich auf beispielsweise
eine außenministerin die die greenpeace
chefin direkt in ihr engstes umfeld holt
und zur staatssekretärin quasi befördert
einen
staatssekretär im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bei robert
habeck der direkt von einem grünen think
tank kommt also purer lobbyismus in der
bundesregierung wir haben eine
umweltministerin die protest die einfach
unangemeldeten protest auf autobahnen
als legitimes mittel des zivilen
ungehorsams geradezu lobt eine
parteivorsitzende ricaner lang von den
grünen die das ähnlich sieht er musste
erst der bundesjustizminister kommen und
sagen mit der peitsche quasi dazwischen
ein unrecht ist unrecht und ziviler
ungehorsam kann kein mittel sein also
wir sehen dass in schulen mittlerweile
abgefragt wird welche co2 footprint auch
sechs oder siebtklässler bereits
hinterlassen also was ich hier
feststellen was ich sagen muss ist das
land wird mir zu grün ich bin ein großer
großer anhänger von klimaschutz aber
wenn ich auch sehen mit welchem werk und
welchem enthusiasmus jetzt das land ich
sagt ganz plakativ zugekleistert werden
soll mit beispielsweise
windrädern mit
solaranlagen auf allerbeste ackerfläche
dann finde ich das extrem bedenklich und
muss noch einmal die warnung aussprechen
das land wird mir zu gründen
also das land darf zumindest politisch
auf keinen fall grün oder noch grüner
werden denn in der tat merken wir an
ganz vielen beispielen dass es dem land
nicht gut tut ich finde übrigens auch
nicht dass man sagen sollte wer die
grünen wähle der macht was gutes für den
klimaschutz denn das gegenteil ist der
fall wir werden nur erfolgreich
klimaschutzpolitik machen können wenn
wir das erstens international angehen
allein die chinesen und die usa stoßen
das x-fache aus von deutschland wir sind
ungefähr zwei prozent der weltweiten co2
emissionen verantwortlich
selbst wenn wir alles hier auf null
fahren die musterknaben der welt werden
eher würden wir das weltklima nicht
retten deswegen wird das nur
international funktionieren und wir
werden natürlich auch nur die menschen
für klimaschutz begeistern wenn es nicht
zur sozialen verwerfungen kommen zur
sozialen einschränkungen und wenn man
zum beispiel sagt okay wir wollen dass
sie auch in zukunft mein urlaub fliegen
könnt aber wie sollen dafür dass fliegen
klimaneutral wird und deswegen sind die
ansätze der grünen er für die
klimaschutzziele schädlich und wir
bräuchten mehr bürgerliche politik und
das bedeutet auf innovation zu setzen
auch soziale marktwirtschaft auf
erfindungen mit denen wir immer mehr co2
reduzieren
und noch ein punkt wo ich machen weil
der ist ganz wichtig die grünen messen
immer mit zweierlei maß die kritisieren
wenn irgendwo aus der wirtschaft jemand
in die politik geht in einem ministerium
geht dann ist der aufschrei recht groß
sie selber holen sich von greenpeace und
von anderen organisationen die leute und
sagen das ist völlig normal und bejubeln
das noch und ich finde es richtig dass
auch quereinsteiger in die politik gehen
und dann muss das auch für alle anderen
gelten und da dürfen die grünen nicht
mit so einer doppelmoral unterwegs sein
sie haben es ja mit einer absoluten
verschiebung auch von normen und von
werten zu tun das meinte ich gerade mit
dem thema auch ziviler ungehorsam über
die energiefrage kann man auch
sicherlich nochmal komplett gesäubert
diskutieren vollkommen richtig aber das
thema ziviler ungehorsam das wird jetzt
visiert zu etwas ganz normalem zu etwas
quasi fast notwendigen aber nur wenn es
um das thema klimaschutz geht ich möchte
mal wissen was passieren extra jetzt
dieses radikale beispiel auch wenn sich
nicht sagt ganz bewusst nazis auf einer
autobahn hinsetzen wird den verkehr
blockieren darunter wäre zu recht da
wäre zu recht in diesem land ganz ganz
viel los ich sage nochmal zu recht und
wenn's klima so genannte klimaaktivisten
machen dann stellt sich die
umweltministerin hin und sagt ja ist
doch gar nicht in ordnung und die partei
position einer regierungspartei sagt
auch bist doch eigentlich in ordnung ist
sie wieder ungehorsam ja also wo kommen
wir hin wenn das jeder für sich in
anspruch nimmt und damit meint die
öffentliche ordnung außer kraft setzen
zu können dann wird deutschland ein
tollhaus sollte die justizministerin hat
ja so die ministerin hat ja sogar
getweetet man kann seine meinung auch
von zuhause kundtun gab ein kleinen
skandal der hertha wenig größer sein
müssen denn die leute die fürs klima auf
die straße gehen da ist es dann in
ordnung verstehe ich nicht was genau der
punkt also und das ist dass da wo wir
aufpassen müssen dass da gerade dieser
regierung nicht gewisse dinge sich
verschieben und zwar
von oben
oktroyiert also das aus mit regierungs
zustimmung ja das schlimme geländer sei
ja normal hätte eine unnütze ministerin
wie frau lemke von den grünen sagen
müssen also das was da einige machen mit
autobahn blockaden die sorgen dafür dass
kari kannten waren gar nicht mehr
durchfahren können das können der
rechtsstaat nicht akzeptieren da muss
der rechtsstaat konsequent vorgehen so
wie man das bei allen anderen ja auch
macht und da sagen die nahe dass
vielleicht eine organisation die uns nah
steht und dann ist man mit zweierlei maß
und das ist am ende auch sehr gefährlich
für die demokratie und den rechtsstaat
denn der rechtsstaat und die demokratie
zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass für alle
die gleichen regeln gelten und nicht für
eine gruppe irgendwelche sonderregeln
und man müsste ja sonst auch irgendwann
sagen wenn vielleicht irgendwelche leute
im rechtspopulistischen bereich am
rechten rand ich bin weit davon entfernt
aber nehmen wir mal an es gibt so eine
gruppe und die sagten wir beanspruchen
solche rechte auch die dürfen das auch
da kann man ganz schwer argumentieren
dass die das recht nicht haben und dann
wird es sehr gefährlich und deswegen
muss man sagen es gibt ja aus guten
gründen demonstrationsrecht man kann
protestieren aber alle müssen sich an
dieselben spielregeln halten ja der
zivile ungehorsam der wird jetzt muss
man dann sagen zum wiedel wort das wird
jeder nutzen der lust auf ein bisschen
randale hat und vergessen hat oder gar
nicht diese demonstration die macht
irgendwo anzumelden ganz klar auch noch
einmal zu sagen für mehr klimaschutz zu
protestieren ist total gut und macht
wahrscheinlich auch ganz viel sinn die
frage ist immer wie mache ich das und
wenn ich einfach autobahnen besetze
damit mich selbst gefährde aber
autofahrer gefährde und einfach den
stempel draufdrücken ja das ist doch
jetzt ziviler ungehorsam bin ich hier
tätige dann geht das natürlich überhaupt
nicht umweltministerin nennt gehabt er
dann auch noch ein ddr vergleichen hier
situation herbei gezogen und hat das ja
ach ja auch relativiert das muss man
fairerweise sagen aber gesagt er wdr gab
es ja auch zivile ungehorsam jeder muss
sich einfach sagen das sind maß und
mitte komplett verloren gegangen oder
umweltminister rente also das ist ja
keine demokratie na ja das wollte ich
sagen also diese fragen werden sehr
stark
moralisiert einerseits und wir verlieren
auch hier ein bisschen maß und mitte wie
teilweise vorhin jetzt mit corona das
ist eigentlich dass man muss man muss zu
einer vernünftigen
diskurs kultur kommen und hier ist es
halt so dass es gibt gute demonstration
und schlechte demonstration in einem
kontext ist eine sache erlaubt seinem
anderen für anderes ist nicht erlaubt
und das das ist oft auf dauer ersetzen
würde ich fast sagen für die für die für
die demokratie und ich würde ja noch
eine sache erzählen und zwar gab es eine
mitarbeiterin der damaligen
staatssekretärin für digitalisierung
dorothee bär diese frau ist aus der
robert beer direkt zu facebook gegangen
als lobbyist denn da haben die grünen
sich wahnsinnig aufgeregt haben riesen
auf schreibt vielleicht auch zu recht
beweis dafür gibt es regeln die muss man
einhalten aber jetzt wo jennifer morgen
kommt alles in ordnung ja man stelle
sich vor man stellt sich vor von einem
automobilen nahen winkt ein institut
würde der chef die chefin herbert wir
gehen da raus kriterium ja wahnsinn da
irgendwie das wird das land würde baby
mir gar keine normale sendung machen
würde alles weg und zwar immer noch zwei
wochen nie wieder so aber
in dem fall und das ist glaube ich etwas
was
wir gerade als journalisten auch immer
extrem gut im blick haben müssen was
glaube ich aber auch eine gesellschaft
insgesamt immer im blick haben muss
messen wir eigentlich mit zweierlei maß
oder essen messen wir mit dem gleichen
maß und
wer etwas in anspruch nimmt für sich
muss dieses recht auch wenn es die
andere seite aus anderen dinge ausnutzt
muss es dem anderen auch zugestehen aber
hätte die union denn jetzt eigentlich
die ampel gemacht also hätte die union
mit den grünen auch gerne
die jamaika oder soja bei der ampel sind
wir noch nicht
also ich habe immer gesagt wenn ich
gesagt nein sie würden nicht nur die
namen aber nicht da bin ich habe nicht
gesagt ich habe immer gesagt wenn wir
gewählt werden dann sollten wir auch
alles dafür tun unsere punkte umzusetzen
dafür werden wir gewählt die leute sagen
ja nicht super die wollen sich dann
irgendwo entspannt dahin setzen und
einfach nur ein paar parolen raushauen
sondern ich habe gesagt wir müssen
versuchen jamaika hinzubekommen
natürlich nicht um den preis der
selbstaufgabe aber die debatte hatte
sich ja relativ schnell selbst erledigt
weil die fdp dann gesagt hat wenn man
das doch am liebsten mit spd und grünen